a big week for you you guys got the the
reunion coming up three words to
describe it
three words terrifying
exhausting
um
oh my god
frightening
where does your relationship end up with
the ladies at the end of this thing you
know i personally was able to work
through my issues at the reunion i ended
up in a good place with any you know
anyone i had issues with but not
everyone did
so it's easier to step away from a
computer and leave things under like
yeah exactly well somebody did
yes
wow way to open that up all right i feel
like erica in the hot seat i don't know
how it's going to go for i feel like
andy asked her all the questions that
you could ever ask but did she answer
them
up to your standards and everybody's
standards she addressed all the
questions that she was asked she was
definitely put in a hot seat it was
the most difficult reunion for her
absolutely
but she answered all the questions she
did not run she did not hide she showed
up
and it was not easy for her and i andy
had a hard job to do he had a lot of
questions that you know he had to ask
and he did so it was very uncomfortable
at times trust me i talked to your
sister earlier there's a tear-filled
moment at the end what can you tell us
something comes up about our mom
and that's always a very emotional
moment and my sister kathy holds a lot
in i'm more of an open person and
kathy just tends to hold a lot in so
something came up and
i think something she's been holding in
it just
just kind of like the floodgates open it
was really interesting to see her like
that and with all the people there and
the cameras because that's really not
how she is
so then they got me going and it was
really interesting and just it was sad
you know it was
i know it was it was it was a hard
moment but i think was actually good for
her
a little a little therapeutic probably
listen tears can heal us all you'd be
surprised i'm i'm a crier i'm probably
gonna cry when i watch it um does erica
leave this thing with any friends how's
she end up
i'm her friend you know yes of course
she has friends you know um
yes she does she does so you turn real
fast around these cameras hi girls hi
they call her the ramona coaster because
she is all over the place tell me about
this girls trip this housewife's
ultimate girls trip just dropped mash up
people are going crazy yeah that was
actually wild that was actually of all
the things i've done probably the most
difficult most exhausting not the most
difficult the most exhausting thing i've
done there was no down time it was
filmed more like big brother style so
there were cameras everywhere in the
house
there was no like 30 minute breaks or
anything i think
no absolutely not so i mean you would
wake up like stumbling they're like hi
can we get an interview like
i haven't even like brushed my teeth yet
so that was wild and you know kind of
thrown together with all these women
from all these other franchises
i think the fans are going to love it
it's a wild ride but
it was exhausting
yes absolutely good entertainment is it
not definitely entertaining though okay
even i was entertained i was like i was
i came into as a cast member and also a
fan so i was like bring me the popcorn
and a margarita
i mean what a what a gift to be a fan
and on it i mean it's that's awesome
call it that
and you call it what you want okay
i'm calling it a gift call it a gift but
go ahead
can we just address the elephant on the
red carpet and it's not me in a squirrel
costume
i mean and that is slightly weird that
i'm in a squirrel costume but you look
amazing head to toe talk to me about
your costume
uh it was the first costume i saw trashy
lingerie and i didn't have a lot of time
i'm going with it's like the greatest
show girl
i like this greatest show woman
yes and you know it feels good and i saw
david gordon green made the same choice
i feel like i'm in good company
right it was like a good choice here um
i was gonna send a picture to jamie and
say
is this okay is this appropriate but i
thought you know she's probably busy so
i i took a risk tonight
run go home now
i am just so honored to be part of such
an iconic film that has been around for
is it 43 years now i mean it's i mean i
kind of want to play that number down
but i think that's the number now and
i'm just so proud to be back doing what
i love so much which is my first love
acting
and i could not be happier and more
honored to be a part of this film and
and i have an another movie coming out a
christmas movie ironically i've got the
horror mov it's called
the um
housewives of the north pole which is
like kind of funny it's not actually
affiliated with the uh actually the real
housewives but it's like a feel-good a
happy funny you know like beautiful
you know visually magical christmas
movie which comes out right after the
this movie so it's it's just exciting
[Music]